اذا ينضم الينا من مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس
مراسل الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي وتابعنا هذا
هذا الفيديو المصور
ل وداع
الشهداء صحيح مؤلم لكن يعني كل يوم يتكرر
هذه تتكرر هذه المشاهد من الثبات والصمود
و نعم هنالك بكاء بكاء الرحمه لكن لا يوجد
[موسيقى]
انهيار في في رغم كل شيء والناس تودع
ابناء
وتودع احبابها مشاهد ملهمه للخيال بالفعل
مؤن نعم زين محظوظ في غزه من
يودع ابنائه او احفاده او احدا من عائلته
لانه يحظى بكرم بتكريم دفنهم تحت الثر
هناك نتحدث عن 8000 او اكثر من 8000 مفقود
لازالوا بين انقاض المنازل التي قصفتها
الطائرات الاسرائيليه منذ بدايه حربها على
غزه ونحن ندخل يومها الثين على الصعيد
الميداني هنا في مدينه خانيونس تجددت
الغارات الاسرائيليه وايضا القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي على مختلف المناطق في مدينه
خان يونس واستهدفت تركزت هذه الغارات على
وسط المدينه استهدفت عدد من المناطق في
وسط المدينه وايضا استهدفت منزلا غرب خان
يونس ادى الى سقوط ثمانيه شهداء حتى هذه
اللحظه الحصيله منذ ساعات ليله امس وحتى
هذه اللحظه مع استمرار واجداد وتيره القصف
المدفعي وايضا الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
على خانيونس نحو 35 شهيدا ولا زالت
العائلات تشيع حتى هذه اللحظه جثامين
شهدائها لمبارات الثر هنا من مجمع ناصر
غرب المدينه ايضا الغارات والقصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي لم يتوقف في منطقه وسط القطاع
والتي شهدت مجزره اسرائيليه ارتكب ارتكبها
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مخيم المغازي
الى جانب القصف المتواصل على مخيم البريج
في وسط القطاع واشتباكات تدور شرق مخيم
البريج على وجه التحديد بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي تحاول التوغل من هذا المحور الى داخل
المخيم ومنه الى منطقه وسط القطاع ايضا
على مجمل الاوضاع الانسانيه هنا هي اوضاع
صعبه للغايه مع نزوح مئات نحو
150,000 فلسطين من مخيم البريج الى منطقه
الوسط وايضا نزوح اعداد كبيره من السكان
من منطقه وسط قطاع غزه مع اشتداد القصف
والغارات الاسرائيليه على مخيمات النصيرات
والبريج والمغازي باتجاه المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا الى مدينه رفح تزداد المعاناه
الانسانيه وسط قدرات وامكانيات محدوده جدا
سواء لدى المنظمات الدوليه او الهيئات
المحليه هنا واقتضاء مراكز الاواء بمئات
الالاف من النازحين مضطر اعداد كبيره من
العائلات الى افتراش الشوارع ونصب خيام
بسيطه جدا في الشوارع العامه تحديدا في
مدينه رفح هنا في مدينه خانيونس جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وسع من نطاق المناطق
التي يطلب ويجبر يجبر السكان من هذه
المناطق على النزوح منها تحديدا مربع ما
يسمى 112 وهو متاخم وملاصق لمجمع ناصر
الطبي من الناحيه الغربيه حذر جيش
الاحتلال سكان هذه المنطقه التي تقع في
مخيم خان يونس من البقاء فيها وضروره
النزوح باتجاه مدينه رفح مع اجداد وتيره
العمليات وايضا الاشتباكات المسلحه التي
تخوضها المقاومه الفلسطينيه مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في المحور الشرقي
وايضا المحور الشمالي من المدينه حيث اعلن
كتائب القسام وايضا سراء القدس استهداف
عدد من الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
وايضا اطلاق العشرات من قذائف الهام اتجاه
التجمعات
وتمركزات للاليات العسكريه وايضا لجنود
الاحتلال قبل قليل وصل الى مجمع ناصر
الطبي اصابتان من موظفي مصلحه بلديات
الساحل الذين توجهوا وفق تنسيق من الصليب
الاحمر مع جيش الاحتلال للوصول الى بلده
بين سهيله شرق المدينه للعمل على
اصلاح بعض اجراء بعض الاصلاحات الفنيه في
منطقه بني سيله لتمديد المياه الى
المحاصرين داخل منازلهم او مراكز الاواء
في شرق خانيونس ولكن قوات الاحتلال ورغم
وجود تنسيق مسبق للطاقم الفني لمصلحه
المياه فانه استهدفهم باطلاق الرصاص الحي
والمباشر عليهم ما ادى الى اصابه اثنين
منهم بجروح نقلوا الى مستشفى ناصر قبل
قليل شكرا جزيلا لك مؤمن شرافي مراسل
الجزيره من خان يونس مستشفى ناصر في خان
يونس